today's a historic day for bitcoin and
digital assets senator lummus and
senator gildebrand coming together to
launch a brand new piece of legislation
that will bring these digital assets
into the traditional financial system
and create regulatory clarity now of
course there's many people debating what
the regulation should be but very few
people have put forward a plan one of
the key pieces to this legislation is
that it's a bipartisan effort it brings
republicans and democrats together and
says we as the united states must
continue to be a leader in the global
financial system if we want to be the
capital of the financial system then we
have to embrace this technology and we
have to be a leader both from an
innovation standpoint an economic
prosperity a job creation and a
financial market aspect now here's
exactly what the two senators were
saying on cnbc this morning fidelity the
largest 401k manager in the country um
announced that they were going to offer
uh bitcoin um to users or to consumers
uh the labor department came out and
said this is a terrible idea what do you
think i think the labor department's
wrong
i think it's wonderful idea it should be
part of a diversified asset allocation
and it should be on the end of the
spectrum of a store of value obviously
if you have a fully diversified asset
allocation you have some assets that you
want to produce income in the short run
you also want some assets uh that are
just a store of value uh and i think
that's where bitcoin really shines
i think it's some of the hardest money
that's ever been created in in the world
and for that reason it belongs as a
slice of a diversified asset allocation
for retirement funds no i agree and
that's why this piece of legislation is
so important and why it's so timely
once you create basic infrastructure
around these types of digital assets
where there are disclosure requirements
where they have a regulator where
there's full transparency
that is going to create the safety and
soundness in the market that will give
other people comfort that this is a
market that is here to stay it's one
that is
properly regulated and one
that has oversight and accountability
and that's what this legislation is
going to do it's awesome to hear two
senators coming together from opposite
sides of the aisle and saying this
technology it's important we need to be
the leader and we have to have clear
regulatory framework seeing both
republicans and democrats come together
is exactly what we need more of in
america kudos to senator lumus and
senator gildebrand both of them leading
from the front and saying bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they're here to stay
and the united states wants to be a
leader hopefully many of their
colleagues will start to follow